[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et bonjour mesdames et messieurs pour
cette grande finale on est là avec Fab
Fab tu es là ah je suis là je suis là
bonjour à tous et à toutes
on va suivre finale on se délecte déjà
d'avance la finale c'est vraiment
attendez le plus c'est voilà ça y est ça
part immédiatement qui ouvre des cas
trop premier coup alors Manu si il peut
toujours et il a choisi des quatre
aujourd'hui pour cette première partie
je fais comme les autres jours je te
laisse le début OK et après tu reviens
et tu vas chercher un peu s'il y a des
infos croustillantes à nous donner par
la suite bien évidemment donc c'est
ouverture c'est un Gambie dame
avec le coup C4 qui vient mettre une
pression sur le centre et western en
général il aime bien jouer que 6 mais
alors il peut aussi prendre bien accepté
ou c'est si cela mais c'est bien aussi
ce qui est joué et une catalane après ce
coup j'ai trois choisis par Magnus
Carson donc la Catalane dont il est bien
expert qu'il avait utilisé avec brio
dans son match contre Yannis
du monde
et voilà donc l'idée un titre catalan on
en parle souvent savoir se fout G2 qui
tape le long de la grande diagonale et
qui va donc être dominant cette
diagonale pendant que le foot C8 lui a
du mal à se développer
Wesley a pris le pion dans ma cadre pour
venir prendre en C4 c'est fait si on les
a fondé 5 justement gagner un temps et
mettre le foot en B7 pour jouer dans le
vis-à-vis de l'autre fou des deux jouets
par les Blancs c'est une ligne qu'on
prenne depuis plusieurs années l'idée de
se fonder de se développer mais aussi
parfois d'aller en A5 pour taper le pion
C7 alors là ça joue vite il a eu le
temps de jouer C6 pour éviter ce plan là
et un coup un peu rare il y a d'autres
manières de jouer mais c'est si c'est
possible et Magnus qui a joué au 3 donc
un coup de consolidation il a cette
belle chaîne de pions maintenant comme
ça centrale
ou tous défend et s'il attaque se fou
souvent donc le fou le cap part ensuite
vers G6
[Musique]
ou le garder là c'est une question
ouverte tout est possible il a choisi
finalement de le garder avec le fou à
chaque fois H5 et Magnus qui joue tempo
Damon donc Magnus complètement dans sa
prépa qui connaît vraiment son sujet
alors à noter on pourrait se demander
pourquoi ne pas prendre ses 6 mais ça
aurait été une erreur c'est un joli
piège par Wesley saut le pion est pas
protégé et a d'ailleurs prendre à ta
créat la tour cela dit non on a fait
tourcer 8 pour attaquer le fou et une
fois que ce fou s'en va il aurait eu le
coup B4 il y aura attaqué ce cavalier
lui-même cloué par exemple des dons
fusées fou G2 B4 de la part des noirs et
le cahier C3 serait perdu à cause du
clouage c'est la raison pour laquelle
Magnus a joué dame E1 dans cette
position si vous souvenez hop dame 1 il
esquive les futurs problèmes le long de
la colonne C et retire sa dame sur quoi
ouais c'est soit je tourne C8 pour
défendre le pion et cavalier E2 une
autre idée de Damien de contrer cette
casse pour quand même aller s'en prendre
à ce fou
donc intéressant un Magnus vraiment qui
qui nous sort une belle prépa mais on
attendait pas moins pour attendre aussi
prestigieux pour essayer de prendre le
lead dès la première ronde et mettre à
Malte son adversaire le mettre un petit
coup sur le casque pour voilà lui saper
un petit peu le moral dès le début du
match un peu comme ce tennis on commence
tambourbattant quand on est un peu plus
fort son adversaire quand on est très
frais lui aussi si dès le début on le
break et ben c'est plus dur pour se
remettre dedans
du coup Magnus qui accélère à fond on
voit qu'il y a 15 minutes 18 alors que
genre qu'on se crée 15 minutes donc il a
vraiment joué très très vite
et il joue donc ce coup de tirer les
deux et on comprend bien que ce cahier
se destine vers la case F4
du coup qui a lieu de jouer
et voilà donc on voit
[Applaudissements]
petit missclique désolé
cavalier de
régler on le fera kiffe plus tard ce
petit demi-finale en haut à droite c'est
la grande finale effectivement on fait
bien de le signaler la grande finale de
ce tournoi
[Musique]
et une chaise
en tout cas Wesley qui marque une
première vraie pause maintenant il a
quand même joué des coups qui qui
connaissaient jusqu'à là
ou qui lui semblait logique mais
maintenant il faut se décider alors bien
sûr C5 c'est un coup logique dans
l'absolu et c'est d'ailleurs le coup
qu'il a choisi de jouer mais voilà la
question qui se pose c'est qu'est-ce
qu'il y a sur X5 et aussi qu'est-ce qui
serait passé sur un coup comme cavalier
4 à venir pour essayer de s'emparer de
ce fou parce que il continue de jouer la
vitesse de l'éclair et qui joue à 5 qui
attaque la Dame des 8 donc il y a pas
vraiment 50 choix enfin il y en a deux à
vrai dire c'est soit dame 8 ok B6 kb6
jamais pas trop la tête du coup puisque
c'est un auto clouage et si on fait KBC
après il faudra se débrouiller avec ce
cavalier qui aura beaucoup de mal à
bouger étant donné qu'il est cloué et
donc on serait un petit peu ligoté
peut-être alors c'est peut-être une
option mais dame 8 semblerait quand même
beaucoup plus logique a priori un
disposition en tout cas Wesley qui
réfléchit d'ores et déjà pour se décider
pour se décider sur quel coup jouer
en tout cas ça fait réfléchir Wesley se
fois 5 déjà plus de 5 minutes d'écart
entre les deux joueurs ça peut vraiment
jouer
ça peut vraiment jouer alors il y a fait
dans mes 8 normalement c'était le quad
directement par qui avait les F4 donc et
qui vient toucher ce foie H5
et maintenant
voilà priori on pourra pas le sauver
même si là il a une case libre en G4
toute façon il serait attaqué donc les
blancs vont gagner la paire de fou quoi
qu'il en soit maintenant donc c'est un
c'est un bon petit avantage de prendre
cette paire de fou
et ok il faut aussi falloir update en
haut à gauche c'est le premier à deux
points ni bien évidemment c'est la
grande finale ce n'est plus le loser
bracket où il y avait des matchs en deux
parties évidemment les gens ont quatre
parties donc pour cette grande finale
quatre parties importante
ce qui sera quand même le temps au
meilleur jardin normalement de s'imposer
on sera normalement bien sûr même si ça
aurait pu être six ou huit pour pour la
grande finale toujours est-il voilà sur
la même règle en cas de 2 les joueurs se
retrouveront pour un Armageddon donc
pour se départager l'armée donc qui ne
sorte de séance de tir au but mais pour
les échecs mais on en est pas là c'est
que la première partie pour l'instant et
Magnus qui passe toujours l'accélérateur
il a 15 minutes 19 à la pendule et il
vient de jouer donc cavalier F4 pour
aller prendre le fou adverse alors ce
fou Wesley peut le laisser se faire
capture en H5 ou peut-être revenir en G6
se laisser capture ici pour constituer
une structure à cash Angers 6 qui double
les pions il restera très compact
c'est plutôt ça son choix qu'autre chose
alors après l'autre question qu'il peut
se poser c'est est-ce qu'il échange ici
ou est-ce qu'il joue avec un coup comme
C4 bien sûr les deux coups sont
possibles l'idée de prendre un des cas
ce serait d'infliger un pion isolé à
l'adversaire puis on isolé donc il peut
être une flèche parfois à long terme
mais qui est aussi une force
éventuellement pour pousser et pour
gagner de l'espace donc est-ce qu'il
prend où est-ce qu'il pousse avec
l'intérêt de pousser ça serait de se
créer un une majorité à l'eldame trois
contre deux il aurait trois pions là
déjà dessiné en bleu assises V5 C4 face
à a2b2 ce qui peut donner un pion passé
peut-être un jour mais bien sûr en
contrepartie laisserait le doute pion
centrale adverse peut-être avancé donc
là voilà ça c'est des choix des
questions à se poser j'imagine que les
deux sont fondamentalement possible
avoir donc ce qui préfère après il peut
évidemment ne rien toucher
et laisser laisser la tension centrale
comme ça E4 serait plus dur à jouer
évidemment puisqu'on prendra en décaps
on a échanger on a une structure
symétrique qui serait pas mal mais en
tout cas bravo Manu c'est ouverture qui
pose problème et question à Wesley il a
pris il y a deux fois plus de temps à la
pendule on le voit et une position pas
simple parce que donc il y a des enjeux
comme ça est-ce qu'on joue avec ces
quatre pour la majorité des dames mais
après il faudra compter sur un coup
comme B3 peut-être provoquer des
échanges en cas de s'éprembé à prendre B
la Torah serait ouverte pour peut-être
taquiner ce pion à 6 par la suite de la
partie est-ce qu'on prend on donne
l'option isoléo blanc mais ça ouvre un
peu la colonne E et peut-être un coup
comme des 5 avant pour arriver
c'est c'est pas d'édition claire et
facile à prendre simplement parce que je
n'ai pas l'impression que les Noirs
égalisent vraiment dans aucun des deux
cas
donc très bonne ouverture de manus en
tout cas bravo à lui il est donc très
très préparé pour pour cette finale
peut-être d'ailleurs une préparation qui
est concocté spécialement pour son match
de champion du monde contre Yann et
promenashi c'est une possibilité
et qui nous sortira là donc une de ces
bottes secrètes
Wesley qui joue fou des 8 donc qui vient
proposer l'échange de ce fou
ah ma foi pourquoi pas il veut essayer
de simplifier la situation cette fois 5
c'est vrai un petit peu pénible qui lui
bloque les pions
donc du coup intéressant au demeurant
après ce qu'il a vraiment envie de
prendre étant donné que ça ramènerait la
dame blanche en 5 je ne suis pas sûr
mais pourquoi pas peut-être que ça lui
simplifier à la vie mais c'est vrai que
l'arrivée de la dame à 5 contrôlera
toujours très très bien les cases noires
et attaquera ce pion à 6 aussi
alors une autre idée bien sûr d'enlever
ce fou ce serait peut-être pour les
noirs de se délivrer plutôt par un coup
comme E5 pour redonner évidemment du
pouvoir d'action à la dame le long de
cette colonie qui était jusqu'à présent
bloqué par son propre fou mais en jouant
le coup des 8 voilà la dame peut
soutenir le pion en tout cas Magnus qui
a gagné la paire de fou il a échangé un
H5 et non repris et ce cavalier H4 qui
était un petit peu hors-jeu et
d'ailleurs toujours sur le sous le feu
du Fou D8 vient de repartir en F3 donc
il se replace de manière centrale très
bien Wesley saut en fait de même
et maintenant on peut s'attendre
peut-être un coup comme tours c'est un
tour D1 voir A4 on peut voir souvent
dans ces dans ces structures
alors me demander si fou baisser quelque
part pour Magnus effectivement faut que
ça pourrait gagner un pion mais le fou
là-bas pour être sans case de fuite par
la suite ce qui peut être dangereux mais
évidemment il faut le regarder donc ce
serait une ça aurait pu être une
tentative
pour rien en tout cas je vais par Magnus
voilà très logique il y aura peut-être
pu aller en D1
dur à dire quel est le meilleur mais en
tout cas il se prend pas trop la tête il
clique et il joue un coup rapide il
continue de mettre la pression sur
Wesley Sow et pour l'instant Magnus donc
nous gratifie d'une excellente partie un
excellent début de partie de sa part
de très belles factures
je ne pense pas que de prendre un 5 soit
une grande idée comme je vous le disais
la dame pourra revenir et qu'on s'est
attaquer des pions un peu il va se
replacer juste avec damesa après à
regarder si ce coup E5 est possible mais
à priori pas tant que ça simplement
parce que les Blancs prendraient d'abord
en D8 et là il est noir doivent
reprendre ça avec la tour c'est avec la
dame et chacun des deux une pièce un peu
bloqué la défense de son pion si on
prend avec la tour on va perdre le pion
c'est 5 les blancs prendraient comme ça
qu'on soit les draps puis on passe assez
facilement avoir un pion de plus si on
prend avec la dame les blancs
prendraient du pion ou du cavalier E5 il
y aurait également un pion de plus voilà
une manière ou d'une autre donc
5 ce serait pas le moment
Wesley qui a joué entre temps il a joué
C4 donc il a décidé donc de pousser ce
pion ici et Magnus a immédiatement
attaqué la structure par l'option B3 le
coup B3 qui qui met sous pression sur C4
qui ne peut pas prendre évidemment ton
cloué puisque il a tortue de derrière et
Magnus continue donc de presser
quelques quelques petits trucs à faire
mais bon je vois je regarde un peu le
stream en anglais et ouais bon ils sont
évidemment
très très excité par cette finale
10 quasiment historique entre entre les
deux joueurs je sais pas si tu as bien
quand même toi aussi fais le teasing
ouais peut-être pas ça peut-être pas
assez extraordinaire il disait que
c'était les préparations de manuscarsen
dans cette partie était du niveau d'une
préparation match de championnats du
monde ça je l'ai signalé j'ai dit que
c'était peut-être une prévention qu'il
avait fait spécialement pour Yann n'est
pas mis aussi dans son match et qu'il a
peut-être gardé en réserve pour son même
très important
c'est exactement c'est exactement ce
qu'il fallait dire Fabien et c'est
persuadé donc
préparation de match de championnats du
monde parce que le match a une
importance pas autant qu'un championnat
du monde on va pas loin mais c'est quand
même voilà c'est assez proche de de ça
de gagner ce tournoi
et donc oui des préparations que tu
gardes que tu as pris pour le
Championnat du Monde et tu les as pas
placés
la Champions League par rapport à une
coupe du monde c'est quand même voilà
c'est ça c'est un petit peu en dessous
mais tu as raison de de le signaler et
je rajoute au delà de ça que les
préparations faites pour ce tournoi de
RC qui n'ont pas été utilisés pourraient
elle aussi inversement vice et versa
être utilisé pour une finale de
championnat du monde ah mais
complètement complètement c'est
peut-être un petit peu juste une
question de calendrier et lequel est
arrivé à avant avant et puis aussi un
petit peu de chance parce que il faut
encore que l'adversaire joue une
position qui s'y prête peut-être que
voilà si Wesley avait joué une slave
cette Manu ça aurait été un petit peu
moins prêt qui sait mais là voilà ça s'y
prêtait très bien oui il a joué la
Catalane qu'il avait employé contre Yann
nepomyachi et bien évidemment il lui
restait des des armes de ce match
Championnat du Monde en réserve et qu'il
a décidé avant la partie d'utiliser en
révisant ces préparations
on verra au prochain tournoi s'il arrive
avec une nouvelle ouverture ça pourrait
être un signe si jamais je voulais
candidats qu'il a épuisé peut-être le
stock ici et justement il faudra
surveiller pour ses adversaires si
jamais il décidait de jouer les
candidats pour reprendre le titre de
championnat du monde il faudra vraiment
vraiment mesdames et messieurs suivre le
prochain tournoi de de cette série du
champion de chaise tour pour avoir un
peu les les dernières
tendances de la mode des ouvertures
je suis quand même content que tu aies
signalé tout ça c'est quand même le
moindre des choses
beaucoup de professionnels dans des
commentaires et ça ça fait plaisir
c'est pour ça que je peux te laisser
complètement
autonomie en autarcie même quelque part
[Musique]
ouais donc toujours très bien qui lisse
et tout qui est un beau centre qui a la
paire de fou il y a beaucoup de choses à
faire valoir donc dans cette dans cette
position
et en plus 13 minutes contre
la finale pour l'emporter oui c'est ce
qui vient du loser bracket et donc qui
Magnus à deux vies quelque part
donc
très dur partie pour Wesley qui a
vraiment à faire un Magnus déchaîné
ouais mais la motivation quand il y a la
motivation du du résultat du tournoi
du Trophée du trophée
ça change quand même quelques petits
trucs
très belles parties en tout cas Fabien
une nouvelle fois je l'ai suivi aussi
partie assez extraordinaire de Magnus
affûté comme jamais est-ce que tu penses
que c'est un signe pour pour la Coupe du
monde je pense qu'il sera en forme
descendante
en tout cas la Coupe du monde à mon avis
il avait son pic de forme après ce qui
va arriver à le maintenir ça c'est ça la
question
mes connaissant à l'athlète c'est quand
même possible
il pourrait
être en pic de forme si il joue au même
niveau même degré de motivation qu'ici
quand même il sera imprenable
très sérieux à la victoire finale
qui manque à son palmarès
mais il manquait le même chaise donc il
est en train de complètement
collectionner les les trophées ils
pourront recevoir un magnifique
aujourd'hui
je remonterai un très rapidement le
trophée
qui est là
le trophée du tournoi à Fabien
magnifique
un retour aux choses sérieuses à la
partie
qui ne trouve pas de solution
je viens jouer
après avoir chasser donc le fou à 5 et
Magnus maintenant qui bon voilà tu peux
prendre son temps
il cherchait quel est le meilleur coup
mais bon un coup simple comme tout rêve
D1 doit être juste très bien une te
ressemble de l'échiquier
magnifique partie en tout cas Fabien une
nouvelle fois
quand même quoi Wesley autant en
difficulté si rapidement d'une partie
non mais bon quand tu te prends des
préparations de type championnat du
monde
en tout cas il a joué au 7
je sais que tu serais friand d'un coup
comme dessin
l'autre tour de coulisser et bien
utiliser les colonnes BC voire de
doubler sur la colonne C pour attaquer
le pion C4 éventuellement
ou pas
c'est pas logique de garder ce fou envie
et de garder des seins qui en option
le chat contre le Père Noël
très bien qu'on jette un oeil quand même
à la qualité de l'air chez carolana
enfin si ça s'arrangeait
ah oui là il a une très belle qualité de
l'air il a que 464 ppm
41% selon l'humidité là là demain je
suis solide
qui continue quand même à
mais bon il a tellement des bonnes stats
à comparer que quand même l'un dans
l'autre ça va bien grande forêt
de tournoi
peut-être dans les prochains mois
d'ailleurs et on comprend pourquoi
très en dessous
macarona qui n'aura jamais réussi à
régler ses problèmes de température il
faudra il faudra trouver les solutions
pour lui et on Pologne tu le faisait
peut-être la victoire de 4 kowski sur
l'étape du Tour de France on se 14
juillet il fait chaud aussi il fait
chaud partout Fabien c'est l'été
peut-être c'est est-ce que est-ce que ça
peut ça peut être un avantage pour
Magnus il est il est en Norvège on sait
qu'il fait moins chaud peut-être qu'il
est moins accablé par la chaleur c'est
bien possible
c'est bien possible ça semble faire la
différence pour l'instant oui au niveau
de l'ouverture en tout cas très
clairement
donc tomber un jouet peut-être B8 serait
possible
il ne l'a pas joué il a d'abord échangé
en C3
et il va prendre ces quatre prochains
peut-être damacat pour venir un petit
peu s'accrocher
mais bon ce pion est en sursis il y aura
peut-être du cavalier 5 pour venir
encore plus l'attaquer
vous pouvez voir dans tous les livres
sur la sur la Catalane
s'est arrêté en décès donc là voilà le
pion c'est 4 en prises mais il y a eu 4
en l'air aussi de l'autre côté sur
cavalue 5 Adam prend des quatre
collecter C4 et assis ou alors il va
attendre un peu ou préparer je me
tordais ou tours
je sais pas un autre coup
compliqué
maintenant faut arriver à conclure c'est
jamais ce qu'il y a de plus simple aux
échecs
tu peux pas laisser de contre jeu c'est
parfois ça la difficulté il a pris en C4
donc on s'attend avoir tout reprend tour
d'un prank avait les provocate qui
récupère le pion de moins et enlèverait
ce tableau
qui le récupérer
et on pourrait revoir l'intérêt de se
fout G2 qui contrôle l'important de
pièces à 8 pour amener le pion à
promotion peut-être plus tard dans la
partie
ça paraît fort quand même Fabien
[Musique]
peut-être qui peut commencer par un coup
comme cavalier E5 s'il le souhaite j'en
sais rien mais
5 enfin moi je prendrai sans trop me
questionner mais après il a le temps
il a le temps Fabien
Dame des trois proposé par l'ordi aussi
avant de suite aller prendre à 6 pas
complètement idiot
et j'aurais peur de ksser 5 et je me
serais arrêté
[Musique]
c'est qualifié apparemment il va pouvoir
filer dans le vestiaire pour suivre la
fin de ce tournoi mces rapide pouvoir
suivre le dénouement
débarrassé de Janick Sinner en 300
pas de place
au hasard
ça réfléchit
le meilleur coup mais bon
mais j'ai du mal à comprendre l'homme
d'être
si je veux gagner du temps je reviens
alors quel le 5 par contre je comprends
plus en train de faire je peux
comprendre alors je sais pas si c'est
bon bah mais
faire le dames des trois de l'ordi sans
le visage en fait
il y a trop fini assez là
je vais pas trop de problèmes à juste
prendre un 6
mais on verra
qui s'accroche qui joue les seuls coups
sur Camille le 5 il fallait absolument
faire dame dessin qui puisque la dame
était attaqué le cavalier aussi donc il
défendait les deux à la fois Dame des
trois attaquer le Kelly cloué il va
revenir avec toi en fait ouais c'est
il va peut-être la rater
ça serait dommage après une telle Master
Class au début et ça pourrait laisser
Wesley on vit dans ce match
on va voir c'est un moment clé en tout
cas les pinceaux
c'est même complètement mais les
pinceaux en fait alors pourquoi pas tu
auras vite rapide de Wesley
quand même surtout il s'est mis mal au
temps ça depuis le début de la partie
mais ça c'est la préparation de Magnus
préparation taille championnat du monde
mais
un peu quand même le seul coup actif de
la position
ça paraît vraiment fort alors moins
qu'il ait une idée qu'on rate
va me prendre
mais au pire
il y aura le fou en prise etc et
bon après avoir s'il y a pas un perpète
dans ce regard
non il y a pas de parfaite donc c'est un
très bien
oui a priori donc tant de B7 très fort
et c'est sûrement le coup ok on va
assister
bien vérifier tout ça c'est aussi
la marque des grands ouais et puis il
peut se le permettre parce que il a
tellement de temps d'avance après son
ouverture que voilà il peut utiliser le
temps à bon escient maintenant
contrairement à Wesley qui a dû jouer G6
un peu en panique après seulement
quelques secondes dans la réflexion
est-ce que Miss sous pression
dès le début de la partie
on demande si on avait promotion pour
acheter le ring sur la qualité de notre
ère alors je crois que j'ai vu un lien
dans le chat qui arrive de temps en
temps je sais pas si c'est pas point
d'exclamation ring
je crois qu'il y a que j'ai vu une
promotion traîner effectivement
toujours en attente Fabien
qui propose un coup intéressant sur le
tour rapide au coup d'avant
on peut te le montrer donc tour à 8 il
propose qu'il y a ici 6 qui intercepte
mais on aurait pu donc prendre la dame
les blancs faisaient une fourchette et
reprenez la dame noire mais donc on
reprend avec le pion on en est perdu et
finalement les pièces noires sont assez
actives
on pourra mettre la tour à A4 si les
blancs des fonda 2 notamment pour
attaquer et des quatre et il y a deux
donc ouais non pour un 8 priori c'était
une option mais bon pas choisi par
Wesley qui a fait G6 et Magnus bon qui
réfléchit quand même bientôt au moins de
2 minutes
faudrait pas se mettre trop mal au temps
non plus
ça réfléchit en tout cas
violemment côté Carlson
35% de réduction en ce moment Fabien sur
le rings wave plus c'est les soldes
c'est les soldes Stan qui va
probablement en profiter
choisi par Magnus qui va les prendre le
pion aussi
il prend maintenant ici peut-être elle
prend pour faire le fameux contre jeu
sur F2 c'est un peu la rendre qu'on
voyait avec une tour en B7 et on pensait
qu'il y a les 7 qui devait gagner qu'en
est-il ici
il y a une différence peut-être c'est
sur quel F7 rang G7 dame prend 7 on ne
défend plus le cavalier attention
en fait
en fait comme ça
je crois il y a pas d'un match 5 mais le
truc c'est que du coup il est temps il
va pas la gagner c'est génial ça garde
le suspense je rappelle que si Wesley
venait à gagner ce match en quatre
parties on verrait après un deuxième
match en deux parties et nous évidemment
avec Fabien ce qu'on espère réellement
c'est d'avoir deux dedans ce match
l'Armageddon Victor
et après encore
et là que le meilleur gagne bien sûr on
ne va pas nous ne sommes pas partisans
mais on pourrait avoir la chance
aujourd'hui de voir
huit parties voilà bien ce serait
extraordinaire
vous êtes fous F6 ici qu'elle est
intéressante un citant les blancs à
prendre des cartes comme ça le four
reprendrait et on arrête toujours la
pression sur F2
je crois qu'on revoit souvent avec ton
B7 ce qu'il a pu louper
dans la même variance
voilà la même avec ton B7 il serait
gagnant par exemple
là oui mais
peut-être ce serait la même avec la tour
embêtée
c'est pas encore fini il va encore faire
tourner 7
plus peut-être pas pour longtemps mais
en tout cas s'il y a plus que des pions
sur une aile et qu'il a le cavalier ce
cavalier pourrait être intéressant et
puis il a pas encore perdu à deux quand
même non c'est pas encore fait parce que
ce qui est ici c'est pas mal ça donne le
contrôle de la case à 5 pour y mettre la
tour
et ouais c'était qui se remet mal au
temps bah faut jouer pour pas grand
chose et là il y a tort B7 c'est fini
tout de suite la gaffe
coût de la position et oui c'est simple
à expliquer puisque après tour 8 on peut
jouer simplement roi et fin on échange
au bon moment tout le matériel et on va
gagner la finale grâce au pion passé
éloigné mais quelle partie
extraordinaire Fabien un niveau de jeu
stratosphérique pour cette finale de
bout en bout c'était très très bien
juste la fin peut-être un peu moins mais
bon ma illustré qui a vraiment mis sous
pression son adversaire qu'il a forcé à
prendre trop de décisions et là à la fin
qui voilà trop de pression qui n'a pas
pu
être au niveau de ce qu'on attendait de
lui parce que la position exigeait pour
pouvoir défendre encore cette finale
difficile avec selon peu de temps la
pendule et puis on a et qui a fait ce
coup de roi laissant tomber 7 le cloué
incroyable ce rêve 7 on s'attendait
alors rien n'est défaites on a toujours
un peu moins vite c'est pas facile à
défendre quand même mais elle était
quand même dure mais bon il aurait ouais
quoi qu'il en soit peut-être le regret
qui peut avoir je sais pas ça serait
peut-être le fou FC sous les dames
prendre ici je je ne sais pas avoir je
sais pas pourquoi il a pas fait ouais
parce que ça forcer d'apprendre des
quatre il faut prendre des quatre et du
coup tu attaques tout de suite F2
et là tu peux regagner merde
[Musique]
ça c'est pas de chance
et si tu commences par 2
moi H6 skyprien
ouais pas de chance
en réussite qui donc maintenant est
menait à zéro et donc Wesley va devoir
vraiment réagir
après il est dos au mur c'est peut-être
là qu'il est plus fort finalement ce
qu'il a plus peur de perdre
mais dommage pour pour cette petite
erreur
allez sur ce Fabien on va mettre une
petite une petite pause
pour la suite donc dans pas très
longtemps je pense que ça va enchaîner
et puis on a une petite surprise pour
vous je pense une course
à tout de suite
[Musique]
match
les amis une nouvelle fois on a regardé
le live en anglais pendant la pause et
on a une autre information très
importante et quelque chose
d'extraordinaire qui peut arriver Fab
c'est si la zavigagne il serait le plus
jeune joueur de l'histoire
qui a été une vision
on va suivre attentivement du coup si
rallye s'est exploitable pour le moment
il y a un demi un demi mais pourrait il
pourrait réaliser un exploit colossal là
ils ont dit que ce serait historique
donc un expert absolument historique
on va voir ce que ça donne Fabien
en tout cas nous on est sur cette
première division et donc cette finale
entre
Magnus si Wesley my husky après une
démonstration dans la première partie et
avec les pièces noires il va falloir
maintenant résister à la furia de Wesley
qui va jouer pour gagner avec les pièces
blanches qui a choisi l'ouverture
anglaise avec lui aussi un fou G2 donc
un peu à l'instar de Magnus et de au mur
Fabien donc
il aura plus peur non il peut plus avoir
peur
c'est un coup un petit peu rare
d'habitude on voit soit le coup c'est 5
on s'est positionné qui se retire tout
vers B6 plutôt que F6 dans Manu ce qui
est parti de l'autre côté
et il fait à 6 donc à mon avis il veut
jouer au 4
et pour l'instant sans H6 sur 4 il
aurait pu y avoir comme les G5
alors que là
H6 petit coup profilactique tiens la
cage G5 et donc c'est une menace latente
dans la position donc je m'attendrai un
coup comme des trois pour les blancs
il décide de continuer en tout cas il
est dos au mur
est-ce qu'un chat
il en reste 6
qui veut prendre Twitter blue avant de
Twitter l'information peut-être
historique
très très fort pas très fort en réel
encore mais il fait très mal sur
Internet souvent donc il a que 17 ans si
on le voit peut-être plus sur Iton il
pourrait très rapidement arriver à 2650
fit voir même 200700 à mon avis vu les
parce qu'il enchaîne vraiment les très
très gros résultats depuis depuis un
moment et je crois qu'il est très très
bien joué en procès League là il joue
très très fort dans les playing il va
gagner peut-être la division 2 donc
c'est un joueur si on le voit plus jouer
en réel qui pourrait à mon avis d'ici un
an ou deux à être 27 voire même
peut-être 27 50
préparation maison pour pour ce tournoi
de Magnus regarde il joue tout tempo
arrête d'être mieux préparé dans
l'ouverture peut-être qu'hier il a
utilisé sa journée pour travailler à
fond c'est vrai qu'on se qu'on se
questionnait de repos elle est casser
son rythme ou au contraire lui permet de
se reposer et de travailler alors ce qui
a joué à 3 donc au 4 c'était pas
tellement un problème vu que ça n'a pas
été joué et il y a eu fou des 6 coups de
développement
qui va préparer le rock
mais quand même ce coup de 4 un jour
sûrement quand même ça sera ça sera
possible
un cookie
qui
va laisser la partie se dérouler là tous
les coups sont possibles pour les blancs
mais c'est vrai qu'elle est peut-être un
peu fragile en s'exposant des quatre par
la suite j'aimais pas mais genre même ça
ce serait pas
on va dire ou B4 c'est quand même l'idée
de A3 j'imagine
donc des cadres pour prendre de l'espace
mettre le fou en B2 sur la grande
diagonale
ce qui est chose faite
petit rock de Magnus
donc maintenant foulées voilà logique
mais il fait des trois à ce coup-ci donc
ça reste logique aussi
et donc voilà on a complètement une
position de sicilienne inversée les
noirs pour une position
et puis aussi il faut dire donc le cas
ici souvent on va viser la case des 4 et
en cas d'échange on reprend du pion et
la tour est bien plaçant à 8 sur une
colonne frappant sur le Pione je pense
qu'on est encore
pour se développer
je les coupe j'ai 4
de toute façon il va bouger son fou là
c'est la dernière pièce à déplacer
exactement il en reste plus qu'une
peut-être aller en eux si enfin et
sûrement plusieurs choix en 17
perso mes petits noms F5 enfin je sais
pas en D7 il m'a l'air de me gêner alors
ça se trouve c'est le Pokémon a choisi
et que c'est pas mal mais
je l'annoncerai un peu dans le jeu
il semble qu'il y a le fou B5 c'était
vraiment un misclick
il semble
pas sûr mais il semble
c'est pareil c'est bizarre d'avoir
aucune prépa après
même de le jouer tout court avec une
prépa mais bon qui sait s'il y avait un
piège ou deux mais là il y avait rien
en mainus qui a joué assis pour freiner
le coup B5 en tout cas si on veut le
faire qu'il le fasse mais
une heure pourrait prendre et ne pas
avoir à bouger le cavalier c'est 6 au
prix d'un échange
tours en tout cas c'est très logique
pour l'instant ce que fait Wesley mais
bien toutes ces pièces il faut aussi se
jouer et peut-être qu'à l'idée de pour
jouer qui allait au 4 et qui a essayé 5
ou qui avait les A4 maintenant côté
blanc
tu fais un peu chiant avec les Noirs ça
mais bon
cette majorité de pions central
mais c'est mal au temps quand même mais
de toute façon depuis le début du
tournoi il joue pas super bien Wesley
tous les jours c'est pas trop comment il
passe il a gagné ce match contre
le cours du jeu et après il a battu kwa
non c'est pas trop comment
ça l'a fait
c'est vraiment il est là un peu contre
le cours du jeu il est un peu emprunté
mais il est encore en vie de toute façon
donc même quand il est pas 100%
[Musique]
pas un apparemment simple
mais bon
c'est pas facile
c'est jamais facile mais peut-être là
encore plus
donc en tout cas tenter
c'est le coup logique pour venir voilà
vers la caisse c'est 5 donc lequel il
avance dans le coin de verre se touche
le fou aussi le pion B7 c'est pas mal et
puis et puis parfois aussi on s'ouvre
les options de faire des tours français
pour abîmer la structure adverse et
gagner le Pione 5 en échange donc un
pion pour la qualité est beaucoup de
jeux donc ça c'est des menaces latentes
ouais c'est un peu mieux pour les blancs
mais après est-ce que c'est grave
ah un joli plan qui est proposé par un
jeu comme dans une ruse
il faut vite rapatrier les fous quand
même
il fasse pousser 8 fois
faible dans la position parce qu'il
aurait déjà ok mais sinon
c'est intéressant
là je suis incapable de jouer avec les
noirs
que Wesley là de ce niveau là je pense
que je demande si la division 2 joue
vraiment moins bien séviant vraiment
fort aussi
j'ai pas trouvé cette division
fracassante en termes de niveau de jeu
on a eu Caruana qui était un peu
emprunté soit emprunté qui arrive quand
même en finale en fait Magnus a vraiment
survolé oui facilement ça c'est ça c'est
sûr mais à côté je les ai trouvé un peu
emprunté peut-être finalement il y a que
Magnus qui a mérité la division 1
il est quand même aller loin alors que
bon on s'en vouloir c'est pas non plus
était un peu emprunté dans ce tournoi
peut-être qu'il fait trop chaud
non mais c'est l'été
il y a vraiment été fort tout au long du
truc mais les autres je les ai trouvés
moins
safitorisent un gars finalement par mais
mais là David peut-être tu as
Biélorussie fait peut-être moins chaud
tu crèves de choses c'est dur de bien
jouer
en Norvège
qui est habitué aux fortes chaleurs à la
canicule
viens est-ce qu'il y a pas une injustice
dans Internet du fait qu'il joue pas du
même lieu et donc ils ont pas vraiment
les émotions aussi ça fait partie du jeu
c'est un peu comme des mécaniciens en
Formule 1
[Musique]
tu es pas sur un pied d'égalité à ce
niveau-là non non exactement il fait il
fait plus chaud machin et tout
de qualité en C6 et sur quel c'est ça
qu'il faudra faire [__]
tout reprendra à priori et peut-être
suivi de fois je crois
il y a peut-être trop de CO2 en Division
en tout cas ils sont pas sur un pied
d'égalité totale les joueurs
ça sera dur dans le match
je pense
bon alors une autre chance avec les
Blancs cela dit il faudra résister avec
les normes dans la troisième ronde
mais là il a vraiment une qui n'est pas
fait
il a vraiment la position qui pouvait
rêver d'avoir
peut-être ça va juste pour Magnus ce qui
est ici 5 bon de toute façon dans mes
jouets on était venu là pour ça il faut
acheter
E5 mais je crois qu'en fait
techniquement ça va marcher étant donné
que sur quel point E5 qui allait prendre
ton temps fou prends un G2 il y a Dame
des cinq échec à la fin et dans l'autre
sens si on prend avec le fou
tu en prends G2 et bêtises pour défendre
alors après on peut regarder
pour les tours et donc avec fois je
crois j'ai l'impression que c'est un
coup qu'on aurait pas dû avoir en fait
parce que
en fait
alors maintenant
ouais peut-être peut-être demain
maintenant c'est pas bête il me dit que
sorry Sota donc oui il doit pas faire
super chaud mais il joue tôt le matin ça
c'est vrai que c'est un autre problème
pas mal avec la clim
deux peut-être
[Musique]
11h c'est pas forcément c'est peut-être
moi réveillé
mais bon ça c'est peut-être le truc à
tenter j'en sais rien
défoncé chez les noirs
[Musique]
sont sur un pied d'égalité quand il joue
contre nous et peut-être pas
un bras d'égalité après je sais que les
américains ils vivent plutôt que nous
dimanche
pour être moins décalé
voilà après je sais pas trop le soleil
se lève à la même heure ou quoi aussi ça
ça peut jouer souvent tu as envie de
vivre avec le soleil
se lève à 6h pareil que s'il se lève à
8h ou quoi c'est un genre de fils du
soleil
non mais je sais pas enfin genre je sais
que dans les dans les dans les îles
enfin quand tu es plus proche des
Antilles ou quoi comme en fait il fait
nuit très tôt 19h et qui fait jour très
tôt vers 5h du matin
tu as l'impression que c'est genre super
tard et tu vas plus facilement te
coucher là et du coup bah tu peux être
debout plutôt et un peu
dans le même mais oui je pense que tu
veux dire Fabien intéressant l'expertise
de Fab bien évidemment
oui mais là c'est une question ça se
trouve
parce que
j'ai 4
5 tours 8 qui prend E5 35 € 8 cavalier
F3 mais il faut prendre 5 cavaliers G4
sûrement bah le problème en fait enfin
c'est pas qu'il y a un match tout de
suite mais c'est quand même tu es bien
bloqué avec les Blancs alors tu as gagné
un pion quand même
mais le cavalier F3 va être
G4 va être bloqué et j'ai 4 boules je
dirais B2
après bah faut jamais se prendre
évidemment
C8 tu as deux pions pour la qualité je
préférais l'autre option pour les Noirs
mais les deux doivent aller
sa chance
on verra ça peut l'air qui va gagner
mais il peut la perdre
même si j'aime bien jouer avec des
qualités de moins
je sais pas ça j'ai l'impression de voir
un loups ils vend des 6 et la marée
centrale
il a commencé par tour assez vite
on repousse le fond F4 tu prends
celle-ci par rapport à
on aurait pu avoir notre cas de figure 7
des 4 qui est des 5
attention
je sais pas j'ai l'impression que tu as
une impression de masse centrale avec
les Blancs et d'un autre côté tu peux te
faire contourner par les tours
de cavalier E5 suivant par le
fouet
tu peux en avoir
pas bien mal mais c'est les soutenu
se passer plein de choses
après peut-être que sur ce 4 on peut
juste ramener la dame attendre 5 pour
faire F6 à ce moment-là
de part et d'autre
[Musique]
mais bon bien sûr H5 ton idée tu as
l'air qui pourra arriver on a pas hyper
envie de voir ça non plus
si tu as joué E4 F5 alors peut-être
sinon avoir je sais pas trop comment ça
marche mais qui a eu ça de faire des 4
et des cinq reparti en D2 avec le fou
allez c'est qui C3
en fait ouais mais
donc
une fois qu'on a fait trois dame et fin
et qu'on laisse ses pions solides le
fout des deux qui pourra repartir vers à
5 ou je sais pas stabiliser pour un jour
c'est pas simple mais en fait en gros
ouais
faut que les blancs en fait arrivent à
stabiliser pour plus tard envoyer les
pions en tout cas il a pas fait il a
ramené la dame aussi
donc au moins le roi blanc on peut un
petit peu souffler
[Musique]
qui est mise à mal
par son pied et son bras de micro et oui
ça vaut lui parler des recettes le bras
Fab et le bras s'écroule
des 5
cavalier C3
d'un bouche qui a valu E4 ou 5 F6 ouais
il y va et après j'ai 5 en fait on ferme
le fou plus de cases
du rap pour Wesley parce que c'est D4
c'est forcé là à moins que tu commences
par cavalier quand même et qu'il y a des
quatre c'est dégueu
non mais il faut faire des quatre on est
d'accord
tu le laisses se faire bouffer ouais
mais ça va être dégueu alors vous
c'était quoi leur temps
ailleurs je sais pas
et après tu me poses des pions pour le
prendre
il faut tant pis
enfin tant pis c'est comme ça et il faut
attendre qu'elle prend F4 j'y prends et
comme tu as une tu vas être dans le dur
sur les colonnes la dame G4 le meuf
peut-être faire tourger un tour G3 après
et c'est toi-même pas facile peut-être
ce coup de trois mal senti par Wesley
après dame 6 qui a bait se couper au 3
bien joué pour faire caillou 7 en deux
temps
on va voir
c'est vrai qu'il aurait préféré pouvoir
pousser ses pions mais il a des
problèmes très concrets qui le force
donc à prendre des décisions autres et
essayer de tenir plus tactiquement il
faudra mettre le fou des 6 sans que le
F5 viennent attaquer d'où la présence de
ce cavalier centrale en Descartes
peut-être ou pas je sais pas
mais du coup il réussit à ouvrir les
colonnes et les tours vont faire mal
voilà c'est clair avantage noir alors
dis donne encore quasi égal mais
ça va être l'ordi
très étonnante
oui bon là c'est la suite logique dans
ce qu'il a fait le problème donc ce qui
est des 4 est beau mais il peut pas trop
bouger et donc Magnus avec ses tours
colonne CCB peut-être mais surtout c'est
peut poser problème parce qu'en fait les
blancs vont commencer deux pions pour la
qualité mais qui ne l'avance pas
est-ce que tu en sais vite
ce que j'aurais fait à tempo comme minus
tu as l'impression que tu vas mater ça
me prend assistant
on va voir carrément j'y crois pas trop
je pense que si Magnus gagne celle-là ah
bah oui
ça peut peut-être plus ou moins tenir on
va voir en tout casser c'est sûr que
c'est la suite ça va
et donc il y aura la tour sur la
première Adam qui se ramener le pion H
qui peut avancer et pas mal de thème
mais bon ok quand même sympa ça au moins
il contrôle la case D2 et
éventuellement froid ou quoi
donc moi je vois pas de bien direct
surtout que oui en terme matériel
normalement deux pions un cavalier c'est
peut-être même au dessus d'une tour mais
on se souvient de la vidéo qu'on avait
fait sur Alpha zero quand il évaluait
les pièces et il aime beaucoup les tours
à 55 si j'ai bonne mémoire
et que et que la tour du coup plus
appartient
[Musique]
la case D1 pour pas te prendre de maths
dame bien quand le je sais pas à quel
moment il a fait H4 en tout cas moi
j'avais H4 aussi en fait
on peut avoir une variance du genre
après fin d'un machin échec pour eux
deux et qu'il y a pas d'un point H2 donc
il est content il sauve un pion
qui pourrait s'avérer important en plus
en cas d'échanges qu'après c'est un pion
à passer exactement
une fois que tu l'as vu c'est hyper
facile évidemment mais je pense qu'on
participe c'est ultra dur
s'il trouve ses gagné
un peu con vu comme ça et en fait c'est
si tu vas avec
rien bah tu fais damage 5 F3 Dame des
cinq et dommage 5 il y a pas qu'elle est
froid en plus parce qu'il y a tort c'est
deux
et sinon
il va pas trouver
bon si tu trouves pas on va voir on peut
se passer plein de choses
mais c'était vraiment dur pour le coup
il enlève le roi de certains échecs le
long de la 8e rangée qui pourrait te
permettre à la dame de revenir allez
Maxime j'ai une dame à 4 ça donne aussi
dame 8 dame 4 échec dans certaines
choses
et peut-être ça te donner aussi du dame
B3 dans cette variante pour couvrir à
deux avec le pion F3 ouais bon c'était
un truc enfin évidemment le Roi Lion est
plutôt en danger mais
pas mal de pions pour plus tard et
peut-être là on peut essayer de essayer
d'échanger ou priez pour échanger j'ai
envie de dire mais
c'est peut-être pas très bon je sais pas
ouais mais après la finale elle est
nulle
avec les Blancs maintenant
ouais mais alors maintenant tu veux
faire tout refait un roi F1 dans machin
et en tout cas
Sagne il y avait je comprends un dame
invités
mais alors après donc oui on aura pas
d'amis sur Madame dermat mais si je fais
pas Madame B3 parce que je perds
bon je comprends mais
peut-être il y aura peut-être tournoi
roi des deux tourbé
ce qui est
dans ma chambre
s'il a dans la chance c'est terminé
[Musique]
courant MP3 et là j'ai l'impression
qu'il est toujours
bien menace
trop impressionnant qui a bien compris
dans cette partie il y a une pastèque
qui était chaude devant franchement
pour provoquer le 3 a marqué ça après
etc c'est c'est bien joué de sa part là
je crois que tu auras un tour bien c'est
quand même relativement facile après il
peut rater
non
on peut toujours tout rater mais
bonnes manières de finir et qu'il a même
pas besoin de faire celle-là
particulièrement
là c'est vraiment c'est inratable
[Musique]
on va avoir une dame de plus contre
mon avis quand même mais je crois que
[Musique]
dame tour et le Cavalaire
il y avait des réseaux de forteresse des
machins final qui va tourner court
Fabien
bon mais le grand favoris en tout cas
rien dans cet endroit
trop fort
un peu comme si la sommet le Tour de
France de la première étape de montagne
à prendre genre 5 6 minutes d'avance sur
ces
concurrents
bon peut-être qu'il a fait ça pour
abandonner en fait
j'ai peut-être une petite chance tu fais
ça pas une petite chance mais genre
ça fait 2-0 Magnus Carlsen qui a besoin
de faire un demi sur deux pour remporter
ce tournoi on va vous mettre une petite
interview voilà c'est le moment
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allez c'est reparti Magnus qui entamé
par E4 cette fois-ci
il faut faire nul hein Fabien on
rappelle l'enjeu nul suffit voilà et
donc je vous laisse sicilienne une
ouverture agressive il est en
l'obligation de gagner donc ne veut pas
jouer simplement une berlinoise
ouverture peut-être dans lesquelles il a
plus l'habitude
quand même hein
il peut le faire il peut jouer
si je le cahier C3 ou un autre coup
ouvrir toute façon pourquoi pas c'est
pas mauvais des quatre mais faut B5
c'est effectivement le coup auquel on
s'attend vu la situation dans le match
je vais me faire pousser quatre ici
trois tu peux faire beaucoup de couilles
il a fait des quatre marrant peut-être
que
non ou alors non non mais attends je me
disais oui il pouvait dire j'avais
exactement si dans tête tu peux te dire
en âge d'or en fait
je pensais qu'il partait dans un pion
empoisonné variante de nuls ou quoi et
de penser à jouer une mauvaise ligne
en réalité c'est vrai qu'on pense
rarement ouvrir la Silène quand on doit
faire nul on dit fou baisser 5 mais en
soi
tu as tellement de lignes où ça joue pas
mais il joue à 4 puis en plus il sait
que Wesley c'est pas son arme principale
la nageoire non loin de là mais
on va voir quoi
combien de pourcentage de chance d'après
toi pour Wesley une victoire dans la
partie ou dans le match dans la partie
je sais pas
10 20 quoi
10 non
2 dans le match de non là je suis très
très peu je n'aime pas déjà deux c'est
bien quoi
donc à 5 il laisse donne la case B6
mais après sur le tournoi mérité parce
qu'il a vraiment tellement mieux joué
Magnus en vrai c'est mérité s'il y a une
la finale en trois parties ça reflètera
sa domination dans le tournoi
un peu déçu
mais
après quoi dire Domini 2000
trop fort
et donc se qualifierait pour la grande
finale de descendre après cette
performance
ce qui fait que peut-être on ne verrait
pas forcément dans les autres matchs
alors attends pourquoi il est pas déjà
qualifié peut-être il a pas encore gagné
de tournoi
je vais aller vérifier tout ceci j'étais
tellement persuadé qu'il y en a gagné
ah ouais tu as raison
qui est déjà qualifié mais c'est
peut-être aussi pour ça que que
[Musique]
ne joue pas ici
car déjà qualifié pour la pour la grande
finale
champions
donc il est là parce qu'il a envie
d'être là en fait pour l'argent
j'ai un doute je crois que c'est 30
c'est 30 qui m'est venu à l'esprit
très bien doté plus de 2 millions sur
toute la saison
complexe
qui est plus fort entre eux dans le sens
c'est jouer sur un Miss League tu veux
dire c'est pas faux il a gagné le
premier match à chacun et finalement il
a quand même perdu sa joué sur un mix
clic
c'est vrai c'est pour ça ton idée de
troisième
ça pourrait s'entendre
les tournois et comme les joueurs
d'échecs adorent rester au tournage
jusqu'au bout même si joue pour plus
rien tu peux avoir des éliminations
consolantes
mais ça existe dans certains autres
sports en fait
genre au rugby à 7 ils font ça tu joues
pour rien mais tu joues quoi
tu joues jusqu'à ton classement final
fait tu vraiment jusqu'au bout c'est à
32 équipes au début
pour la 38e
pas avoir un double élimination mais
juste des tableaux et tu continues à
jouer jusqu'à ce qu'on fait c'est 8e 7e
6e 5e 4e 3e 2e ou 1er
mon rugby à 7 ils font ça ouais tout un
tas de match tout le temps
parce que tu peux pas enchaîner les
matchs tu as besoin de te reposer assez
physique et comme ça joue sur trois
jours peuvent pas jouer non-stop donc en
fait ça meuble les temps morts les
matchs de classement
ça leur laisse trois quatre heures à
chaque fois
tu fais tu fais ton match qui dure quand
même avec la mi-temps et tout ça durait
18 minutes un match elle m'a haute
intensité tu peux pas enchaîner quatre
matchs par jour enfin c'est trop
tu fais tes matchs mais tu te tu
souffles pendant que les autres je leur
match de classement
le public comme ça voit des choses mais
voilà et toi tu reviens bien frais et
pour le grand match pas forcément frais
d'ailleurs des fois ça joue le physique
quand même
H5 on pourrait peut-être voir un tour à
4 tours G4 aussi après ouais
un petit tour à 4 pas piqué des haines
ton
cou ici on part sur les plans avec eux 5
qui peut mettre un peu de piment à la
partie mais n'importe quel goût comme
dame F3 juste de placement ce serait
peut-être pas mal aussi
je pense que saut il croit encore un peu
ou pas du tout pas trop je pense mais
bon c'est quand même un grand combattant
donc
très haut blanc en tout cas
après ça les buts nous dit qu'il joue
pas pour l'argent et pour empêcher aux
autres de gagner de l'argent
Magnus
qui trouve que c'est une belle théorie
le score du match mais il y a 2 € pour
Magnus qui donc dans cette partie n'a
besoin qu'une partie nulle pour
remporter le match et le tournoi
donc autant dire que il est très très
très favori
elle réfléchit
un petit peu comme monnaie peut-être 3-0
au foot à 75e minute quoi
voilà mais bon
je serai la situation inverse
quand même mais bon tu peux toujours
suer à te dire ouais bon c'est quand
même Magnus en face ou quoi mais bon
ouais 4 bien joué
voilà un coup de développement il prend
pas trop de risques
[Musique]
rien à dire en plus ça prend la caisse
B8 comme ça il y aura pas de tour B8
sera probablement être un couple noir
était bien content de jouer pour un
petit peu s'activer
donc donc pas mal ce fou ici
un peu déçu ne bat jamais Magnus en fait
alors détrompe-toi il l'a quand même
battu dans final du Global chest tour
non
dernier alors un petit peu dans des
dans d'autres tournois comme celui-ci
en début de saison où il y a deux ans
mais effectivement
sur Internet enfin un moment donné là il
a une période où il gagnait un grand
rush tu étais vraiment à son top
mais oui c'est rare des joueurs est un
score positif contre Magnus de toute
façon dans leur ex up
je sais pas si il y en a en fait alors
sur une partie ou deux peut-être mais
quand tu as déjà contre lui sur 10
parties 15 20 30 50
un moment c'est dur
et donc Wesley avec un Mégane
une pierre quand en dernière partie là
c'était un magnifique spectacle mon
dernier déjà on est content ensemble je
crois avec des joueurs qui étaient à
Belgrade et d'autres
au Canada je pense c'est Toronto
jolie ville
je pense qu'il existe avec 5 la F3 E5
par la suite de la partie pour donner
vie à fouber7 qui va pas rester il
l'espère derrière les pions comme ça
tout le long et une fois qu'il a fait
ses 5 il aidera fan pression sur le sang
devient disparaître ou avancer ou quoi
donc c'est pour l'idée qu'il a derrière
la tête
après peut-être Magnus qui attend ses 5
justement faire le 5 c'est comme ça
qu'il y ait des 7 n'aurait pas accès à
la casse C5
aussi tu fais un petit coup de
temporisation avant
j'ai 3 torché 8 fois 6 des choses comme
ça
après il est peut-être encore plus fort
c'est dommage c'est 3F 7 damage 5
j'espère en répétition
G6 du coup damage 7 8 dame prend G6 au
F7 et à toi 7
ça peut
parce que bien sûr sera très content de
faire nul
puisque nul gagne le match et le tournoi
il vient de 5 attaque le cavalier en
général ce qui arrive va se replier en
17 ça casse logique
et donc peut-être un coup comme tu
reprends je vais essayer de rendre de
nul
tu vas peut-être faire
G6
moi ça se peut que je laisse
par flemme
non mais un moment de toute façon si tu
peux pas tu peux pas
et tout mais je pourrais laisser juste
parce que j'en ai marre en fait oui
F5 c'est peut-être un coup pour éviter
justement ces histoires de tout
reprendre 7 et compagnie
après ce qui peut ce qui peut tenter qui
est ici 5 sinon
apparemment enfin peut-être je sais pas
pourquoi
j'ai pas vu un peu ce qu'il a fait la
partie précédente
parce que partie précédente je peux pas
croire que il est pas
je pense qu'il y a pas de laisser
réfléchis trop pour le laisser
je sais pas il peut le laisser
moi je laisserai perso
il laisse pas
toi
non
j'ai pas vu elle a compté trois minutes
dessus
tu peux pas quoi
objectivement mais juste moi j'aurais
été découragé
tu en as marre de perdre en boucle sinon
un certain moment ça suffit non de
perdre en boucle oui bah c'est chiant
mais bon c'est la dernière au cas où
ah oui
mais tu as ta masse de pion centrale tu
es pas encore en train de te faire mater
non plus même si les pièces blanches
commencent à se montrer un petit peu
de leur nez on va dire
mais
ça va donc là bon bien sûr faut G5 c'est
une menace attaque la tour et puis après
le pion aussi
donc peut-être il faudrait faire 5
maintenant chasser ce fou voilà la masse
centrale qui pourrait continuer à
avancer peut-être ou ramener ensuite le
fond C8 chasser la dame
c'est une potion complètement jouable
pour pour Wesley qui vient d'avoir de
jouer le coup 5 auquel on s'attendait
un peu il a envie mais Wesley peut être
content parce que là il a un beau centre
honnêtement
voilà 5 jouets peut-être un peu trop
facile en voyant c'est thème de nulle
peut-être etc
et donc on va voir
le gamer qui demande le score il y a 2-0
pour Magnus pour l'instant et donc cette
partie peut se contenter de la nul pour
l'emporter
mais Wesley tu vas pas laisser la nul
cela qui joue avec sa masse d'option
centrale qui attaque le fouet Fiat
il y a pas de sacrifice pour faire nul
le roi pour l'instant pas trop mal
défendu là tu reprends revenir en F7 si
besoin pour défendre le purge 7
coulisser défendre
elle a totalement trolls
trop facile
tout le temps et de se faire violence
[Musique]
je vais répéter
ça à remettre du suspense dans ce match
Fab exactement même si bon déjà la
partie n'est pas gagnée et quand même on
se la viendra s'imposer encore gagner et
encore gagner et encore une image
d'après mais ça serait déjà un premier
pas de toute façon de faire il a pas le
choix une étape obligatoire s'il va
rester en vie pour la suite du match
dans cette finale après hier contrat de
photographe il a fait un peu pareil
Magnus finalement oui mauvaise partie et
puis ils sont sortis un peu par miracle
par miracle c'était cadeau aussi
après je peux comprendre quand tu gagnes
toutes les parties sans aucun problème
bon au bout d'un moment
tu vas sentir tu peux abuser quoi
pour se mettre dans le vis-à-vis de la
dame et de la tour mais
et chasser petit à petit les pièces
blanches agressives vers son 1 les unes
après les autres Fabien
voilà c'est chose faite
l'adversaire a le centre il a fait Fiat
pour se faire chasser à ton âge 6 la
casse vite maintenant peut être contrôlé
par la tour qui pourrait venir attaquer
le pion B2 puis rentrer un jeu via B4
première
au centre peuvent avancer à tout moment
notamment le pion eux qui vont venir en
quatre attaquer le fou lui donner la
case de 5 au cavaliers donc il y a plein
d'idées côté noir
et une belle position
on l'a vu d'ailleurs dans cette fameuse
partie dont tu parlais avec
ou même complètement foutu la cam
essayez de défendre la finale de Tours
jusqu'à y arriver pour la rater il y a
ça
ça peut arriver même aux meilleurs
ça devrait pas mais ça peut être
vraiment facile
je complique les échecs
facile plus facile il y aura du mal à en
avoir ça c'est sûr
pas tous les jours qu'on a plus dans une
finale de tours sans contre jeu en plus
sans contre-jour des pions qui avance
etc mais à un moment ça va faire un
blocus c'est incroyable
comme ça plusieurs reprises
l'avancée
un qui a peu de temps maintenant bientôt
moins de 3 minutes
6/42 pour Wesley qui se débrouille très
bien dans cette neige Nord
relâchement coupable pour Magnus
genre vraiment pas la sauver celle-là
alors vraiment pas
va vraiment perdre des tempos elle est
vraiment mal placée
ça peut arriver après c'est un match en
quatre parties donc
ici en prochaine il fait un résultat
positif pour lui ça suffira largement
et comme on dit celle-là elle est pas
encore perdu même si même si c'est
vraiment difficile pour lui
dans cette position
il a choisi le courser 3 donc il enlève
une de ces deux grosses pièces selon de
la grande diagonale
attention parce que généralement quand
tu te ressaisis après
ah bah là il va franchement il va
essayer s'il peut conclure le match
maintenant il va pas laisser des espoirs
à l'adversaire pour pour le plaisir de
lui laisser
je pense
néanmoins de te remettre à fond et de
revient cliquer en disant je suis plus
fort que l'autre je vais
ça va suffire
qui gagne un tempo sur la dame peut-être
le coup au 4
qui attaque le fou une fois que celui-ci
on va bouger cailleuse 5 à ce moment-là
je pense que 4 qui donne le plus envie
ouais moi c'est le coup que j'aurais eu
envie de jouer après peut-être ça lui
fait peur le fou H6 qui reviendrait vers
3D 4 etc du radis mais
qu'on aurait envie de faire on branle
les pions on se donne la belle case de 5
pour le cavalier
après peut-être 4
on peut sacrifier qui
est bizarre mais bon
je dois me prendre 4
pions pour la pièce toutes nos pièces
qui restent très actives le foie ou des
deux pour aller sur un autre diagonale
tu peux peut-être c'est ça le souci
aussi c'est vraiment le coup qu'on a
envie de faire s'il est blanc sacrifie
pas on se dit bah c'est cool mais
peut-être ce coup de pied prend 4 qui
pourrait faire tourner les choses avoir
Magnus qui s'est bien repris il réussit
à faire réfléchir sa
justement il est bien faut cliquer c'est
important cette pression autant on l'a
vu après la partie du match ou
finalement
un petit peu apprécié Magnus
mais après c'est le défaut de saut c'est
quand il est mieux il veut trop
contrôler
on n'est pas encore à ce moment là il
est mieux mais il est pas
écrasant non plus alors il a fait 5 il
attaque la lame attention là mais
rentrer à la maison maintenant 4 après
il joue précis mais comme tu le disais
il enferme la tour G3 mais il y aura fou
G5
noir une victoire de Magnus en trois
parties je trouve que ça reflèterait
vraiment le
niveau puisqu'il a vraiment marché sur
le tournoi Wesley a pas enfin pour moi
était loin de son meilleur niveau
et finalement voir Magnus l'emporter si
facilement
ça refaitait à 200% ce qu'on a vu tout
au long de la compétition à Fabien oui
oui exactement
mais bon on est dans une finale et
peut-être cela va trouver une force en
lui
le tour V8 il active sa tour il attaque
le pion B2
j'ai 5
et H4 à mon avis
peut-être B3 d'abord
prends un G6
les 320
pour Magnus non non juste des pièces
un peu prises dans l'étau des pions
adverses mais c'est tout il y a encore
de catastrophique dans sa position et
surtout que la tour maintenant peut plus
être attaquer par le fou donc elle est
là
tu fais un B3 qui prend des trois tu
auras tout reprend
problème c'est plus que tu vas te
prendre un E4 à bonne escient
pas mal ce qui va aller à 4 le F1 quand
même une force c'est qu'il attaque ce
pion à 6 Fabien
certes effectivement bloque un peu le
fousset 8
le 4
j'aurais bien fait avant je l'avais déjà
signalé mais maintenant pourquoi pas
peut-être
pour aller vers F4 après bon ça sera
plus possible maintenant
il y a quand même
mais il est revenu au temps regarde
et ça c'est une bonne nouvelle pour lui
c'est une très bonne nouvelle pour
Magnus qui accusait peut-être jusqu'à 4
minutes de retard en cette partie
position difficile elle l'est toujours
mais déjà il a fait l'effort à la
pendule
prise à 4h prendre à mes fuites ça
attaque le pion F2
d'un E3 mais sur chaque coup il peut y
avoir ton B2
surprise
[Musique]
à la fin en fait si tu prends tout il
veut tout refaire
mesdames C5 jouer force le roi
cloué maintenant
[Musique]
un peu moins
ce qui va quand même pouvoir sauver ça
il reste 40 secondes entre une 30 en
face
de trois pions prend et surprise B2
tours 8 repenser 8 et c'est de jouer
cette finale tu es le plus en B3 il y a
6 qui est un peu faible
20 secondes attention
bon après il y a quand même trois
secondes de rajout parcours donc
il y a plus le temps de trop réfléchir
alors il a pris on s'attend à Tours
quand même maintenant
je veux pas prendre un jour autre chose
je veux pas non plus mais bon vu qu'il
réfléchit doit chercher autre chose de
peut-être encore mieux et parfois il
suffirait juste de jouer de garder la
pression à la pendule et voilà donc il
l'a quand même fait prise fougé de
l'attaque la dame il a joué comme ça
après comme on disait c'est un peu la
les le le défaut de saut c'est que
parfois il veut trop assuré il va faire
il fait C3 comme ça pour ça
c'est pas mal aussi il se développe donc
il y a plus le fond F1 il a pas besoin
de défendre à 6 va faire Dame des deux
je suppose
tour qui pourrait venir participer un
petit peu au jeu
peut-être dame F3 échec puis on prend
prise
c'est logique
fais-toi un direct
c'est quand même ça défend tellement
bien
c'est horrible à gagner contre un tel
plus 35 secondes
il y aura peut-être des tours à 5 en
plus en certaines lignes portant
G2
il a pas trouvé
il a raté une égalité d'après l'ordi
pour revient de me faire venir à son
tour quand même non
5 c'est moins fort en plus il va faire
B4 il consolide
il a une meilleure position mais
maintenant il a plus l'avantage à la
pendule et il patine il pète dans la
semoule depuis quelques coups il y a pas
les goûts il menace faut prendre à 6
pas grand chose mais en tout cas il est
en place il faut jouer pour Magnus
ah il a trouvé
et maintenant ça fait mal c'est 4 mais
avec un tempo de retard fallait le faire
au coup d'avant je vais prendre ce pion
h il a deux pions de plus maintenant
il y avait dame B6 encore qui faisait
nul
raté par Magnus oh il en a raté des
occas hein Magnus ici et abandon je
crois que c'est la première des fêtes de
Magnus du tournoi 2 ici et il a raté il
a raté
c'était pas facile mesdames Messi c'est
vrai que si tu le vois c'est hyper fort
voilà c'est changer d'âmes en cas de
pression prend le pion est à deux cases
de promotion donc c'est un danger
mais il avait donc victoire de Wesley et
il restera donc peut-être une ultime
partie mais on espère pas le match
continue mesdames et messieurs on se
retrouve après la pause du partenaire
and chess à tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et c'est reparti Wesley qui entame un
nouveau par C4 au premier coup comme
lors de la première partie où il a eu
les blancs Magnus qui joue cavaliers F6
qui relief 3 donc on a une autre
variante on avait vu une vente avec E5
là ce sera un petit peu différent
puisque évidemment le pion E5 se fera
capturer donc Magnus qui joue E6
donc un coup qui prépare éventuellement
le coup des 5 et qui ouvre le fou et
fuite des cinq jouets il prend le centre
le Wesley pourra jouer D4 pour tomber
dans un grand bidame ou peut-être un
coup comme E3 pour jouer dans un type de
jeu voilà plus un peu derrière les
fagots le coup E3 moins théorique
une nouvelle fois et ils disent que
Magnus a peut-être été trop confiant oui
peut-être trop confiant lui c'était trop
facile ils ont un peu comme nous en fait
au final
et donc ouais gambidame il a besoin
d'une nul hein Magnus toujours voilà
donc les cannes dans une dans une
situation favorable un petit peu moins
que il y a
il y a 40 minutes de ça mais ça va quand
même
il perdrait ce match en quatre parties
il faut quand même rappeler un enjeu
c'est que lui il a le droit de perdre
mais comme ouais c'est so vient du loser
bracket
mais il faudrait qu'il y a une deux fois
deux matchs donc là Magnus annonce alors
un avantage en ce match là mais quand
bien même il le perdrait il y aurait une
deuxième vie c'est un petit peu comme un
Mario exactement tu as encore une vie
quoi tu peur tu as un champignon qui te
tape dessus
mais tu reviens quoi
tu es pas si mal
voilà voilà
alors à noter bien sûr que dans le
second match ce sera un match en deux
parties seulement oui
ce serait deux parties exactement
mais étonnamment si tu fais match nul
dans le premier il y a quand même
l'armée donc t'as pas un avantage total
c'est une règle qu'ils ont changé c'est
au tout début du champion de chaise tour
tu pouvais faire tu pouvais marquer des
demi 7 d'accord là c'est terminé
maintenant exactement les règles qui
datent il y a deux trois ans Fabien mais
qui ont été adaptés pour plus de
spectacles et comme on le voit c'est
plutôt réussi exactement au format 2023
donc
mise à jour après peut-être de grande
réunion
pour décider si point de détails mais
finalement n'en sont pas et qui
permettent
plus de suspense puisque sinon le match
aurait déjà été fini après la deuxième
de l'histoire
donc une position qui pourrait être
complètement symétrique après qui avait
laissé six
mais ce n'est pas un coup obligatoire
bien évidemment côté noir
pourrait jouer un peu comme à 6 un coup
qu'on a l'habitude de voir dans ses
positions pour prendre en ces quatre à
tirer le fous sur la case et jouer B5 à
ce moment là
mais on pourrait je pense bien sûr
sur mon pion prend pour un pion isolé
assise donc théorique tout ça bien
évidemment Fabien peut-être pas de
championnats du monde aussi un qui sait
très possible puisque Yann parfois joue
l'anglaise et donc
il faut être prêt
tout l'avantage de jouer les matchs
champions du monde c'est aussi de s'y
préparer
de plusieurs mois et donc après ils sont
vraiment très près donc bien sûr pendant
le match mais vu que le match ne dure
malheureusement que 12 ou 14 parties ils
ont pas le temps de tout jouer et donc
ils ont encore des ventes en stock pour
utiliser ensuite dans leur tournoi
personnel
l'année suivante ou dans les mois à
venir en tout cas
en tout cas ce tournoi a quand même un
price poule un très très important
exactement sur 5 jours 30 000 dollars de
au premier c'est pas c'est pas tout le
temps c'est pas anodin non non bien sûr
lundi mardi mercredi et vendredi
seulement
qui n'a pas joué et surtout qu'il est
qualificatif un manus c'est déjà
qualifié pour le prochain donc
de garantie c'est un peu un effet cumulé
en fait cumuler donc quand tu mets tout
bout tabou sur une saison ça peut quand
même aller pour pour vingtaine de jours
de compétition sur du 200 250 000
dollars tu vas si tu vas loin en finale
et c'est pas anodin mais c'est pas
anodin bien sûr bien sûr
[Musique]
oui donc du coup on a pas du tout une
position de pions isolée on a une
position un peu différent d'une
structure ou les normes ont pris
l'espace à l'eldame
coup qui couvre l'échec et les ventes
fous n'est pas une erreur et oui je
m'attendais plutôt un coup comme petit
rock peut-être
mais donc oui dans genre structure faut
que les Noirs fassent attention aux
pions des 5 qui est un petit peu la base
de la chaîne d'opiant qui est dans le
viseur du fu G2 qui peut être une
faiblesse mais bon pour l'instant est
bien défendu au cas où les noirs peuvent
faire [__] ces trois pour éliminer un
cavalier qui pourrait être un attaquant
de ce pion
donc pour l'instant rien à craindre
là-dessus mais à surveiller quand même
et puis une autre idée pour les blancs
c'est arrivé à faire B3 pour casser
cette chaîne de pion mais bon pour
l'instant pas vraiment possible ce que
ces trois besoins de soutien du pion B
donc donc pour l'instant tout va bien
côté noir
à noter s'ils veulent vraiment renforcer
ce centre il pourrait jouer qui est ici
et sur cavalier prend prendre du pion B
d'ailleurs c'est ce que Magnus a fait
histoire d'avoir une structure bien
solide allez une bonne position
ah oui bah c'était un petit peu un
avertissement la partie précédente et
donc là il a l'air très averti un homme
averti on vaut deux
un homme préparé en vaut 4 donc là lui
il est averti et préparé on le sait
peut-être un coefficient multiplicateur
donc là combien de cartes scènes
sont-ils
dans la partie là elle est
beaucoup mieux partir en fait avec les
noirs que ça avec les Blancs
plus stable il est pas parti à la
bordage
le slid
F4 mais qui est quand même
on n'a pas envie avec cette colonne
semi-ouverte ça sera un gros tronc au
cap le plus de 3 un petit peu exposé et
surtout ce qui a lieu 5 là il est beau
mais si un moment les Noirs arrivent à
faire et si le chasserait et les
faiblesses ça va vraiment exposés
ouais
mais bon ça reflètera cette finale enfin
moi je suis quand même plutôt pour Manu
ça reflète tellement le tournoi
Dra à défendre le Cavaillon de 5
donc ce n'est pas une gaffe qui perd un
pion est-ce qu'il y a des mesures
anti-triche ce genre de temps a
complètement les joueurs doivent
partager leur écran
donc on voit on voit ce qu'ils font sur
leur écran et doivent notamment mettre
aussi une caméra derrière eux donc
le partage d'écran donc on est vraiment
bien sûr quasiment persuadé à
99,9% que les joueurs ne peuvent pas
tricher c'est c'est très très contrôlé
nous-mêmes on joue ce genre de tournoi
de temps en temps donc on sait que c'est
semble vraiment impossible
c'est vrai que les deux caméras quand
même couvre beaucoup d'angle en plus de
de soulever une caméra l'autre pour
montrer tout ce qu'il y a autour de toi
le plafond peut-être
exactement et
donc on verrait si avec quelqu'un caché
ce serait pas possible
ça serait pas possible
donc voilà les mesures mais qui ont
évolué depuis plusieurs années d'abord
il y avait que la webcam je crois au
début il y avait que la webcam devant et
le partage d'écran et
après on en est passé à deux caméras une
devant une derrière et le partage
d'écran et c'est pas ça une caméra
devant une derrière partage d'écran et
on peut te demander de soulever tout le
moment de soulever la caméra et de
montrer à 360 degrés toute ta pièce pour
être sûr que personne ne soit
te donner les coups
souffler les coups peut-être murmurer
alors il est chevaux
la seule solution à laquelle moi j'avais
pensé mais je sais pas si je vais la
dire
moi je suis curieux
alors c'est quelqu'un qui le dise
oralement
la pièce mais qui te disent les coups
c'est vrai que c'est fino dur d'y penser
un complice donc une deuxième personne
dans une autre pièce alors pas forcément
ça peut aussi être juste avec un
haut-parleur ou quoi qui te disent les
couilles
derrière tu as camoufler ah parce qu'ils
n'ont pas le son avec les
[Musique]
on n'est pas sûr sûr juste 99.9 quoi
peut-être il y avait 0 1% de chance que
quelqu'un
haut-parleur
un peu peut-être comme ça des miroirs
des choses comme ça
un jeu de miroir ou genre de truc que tu
pourrais
pas avoir mais bon ça demande quand même
une sacrée organisation et puis tu
aurais quand même une chance de te faire
choper c'est-à-dire que c'est obligé de
couper ton micro ou
que le miroir
tombe la trappe ne trappe pas très bien
il y a un vrai risque
dise un truc qui vibre dans la chaussure
ou quoi ouais ce serait une autre
possibilité mais là encore c'est pas
facile il faut comprendre le mort il
faudra avoir quelque chose caché
dans une chaussette ou quoi alors
peut-être que la caméra pour être bon de
regarder tes chaussettes je sais pas
nous pourriez avoir joué il te demande
quand même de
pas il te demande beaucoup de de tourner
la caméra etc ouais
bon c'est très très sécurisé
il faut quand même en jeu on peut pas
prendre de risques
[Musique]
le risque zéro n'existe dans aucun
domaine mais mais en tout cas des
efforts les efforts fait permettent
d'être quasiment sûr quasiment certain
et donc Magnus qui a joué je ne sais
plan favoris de pousser ce pion h
qui va attaquer le fougeret2
noir et puis dans toutes les finales un
cavalier G4 qui a attaqué H2 c'est
toujours pénible donc c'est quand même
une épine dans le pied à long terme à
chaque jouet
4 qui peut arriver peut-être enfin
mettre le fond en 17
[Musique]
blanches qui sont très très bien
contrôlés on va se pion C6 le pion des 5
le plan H3 on voit le vice du chat
puisqu'on disait de faire des spots
lasers que tu peux faire avec les coups
c'est les lasers tu peux tu peux les
trafiquer pour pouvoir écrire le coup à
envoyer un coup de laser
sinon je ne savais pas
très très vicieux dans le chat il vaut
mieux pas que vous jouiez ce genre de
tournoi mesdames et messieurs
regardez un vice pas tenté
pour l'instant
il déroule
extrêmement bien
évidemment avantage noir ici ça se voit
dès que Manu ça appuyé sur
l'accélérateur ça fait la différence
plus personne qui peut suivre ça va trop
vite
j'ai 4
oui ça va
ça fait mal
pas facile pour souvent que en plus
gagner cette partie pas seulement
défendre une position pas facile
c'est pour ça que c'est l'idée qu'on
avait juste avant ouais oui quand une
très bonne idée on a changé donc ce
cavalier 3 qui pouvait aider à défendre
les cases blanches et en le supprimant
ben on a eu deux pièces qui jouaient sur
quasiment je le Fuji enfin j'ai quatre
le footl classe blanche en tout cas et
le cavalier 6 alors après peut-être
qu'il a rejeté pour l'instant puisque en
reprenant ces trois ça ouvrait la
colonne C etc mais ça reste un plan
latent dans la position
et clairement il serait très content
d'échanger les fous de caisse blanche et
son faux contre le cavalier pour laisser
blanc avec un mauvais fou et en profiter
avec une dame qui pourrait peut-être se
diriger vers F3 pour les matins en G2
français 3 et cavalier prend le 4 en
fait il y arrive pas tu aimerais mais tu
arrives pas
de bien jouer dans les complications en
plus un savoir-faire positionnel qui n'a
montré tout le long du tournoi on se
souvient de ses pions doublés C4 qui est
tombé il a dû modifier mais qui avait
perdu fascinant cette position
entre jardin une forest il a aussi bien
joué bien manœuvré la position technique
peu de françaises
et donc il est il est tout terrain
il peut toujours
bien sûr on échange pas se fout des deux
qui est tout pourri
one pas les changer après à calculer si
on peut s'en aller voir si ce soit sur
dame prend ceci mais normalement on doit
pas le prendre
ils sont tellement vicieux dans le chat
il pense avoir des des lumières
intelligentes
tu peux juste mettre un petit coup de
fouet 600 jouable
leur vie ça n'a pas de limite
et bien joué Magnus ça doit me prendre
aussi prends des quatre attendra les
blancs puis on prend tour C8 attaque la
dame quand la dame bouge-toi
[Musique]
alors ceux qui tente de gigoter
et peut-être qu'il veut espérer un coup
comme F3
du mal à y croire
des cas dans la foulée le roi très
faible sera diagonale
est un problème bah il y aura quand même
peut-être trois
H2 mais bon on pourrait prendre cette
tour dans le coin
déjà ça c'est un problème tout un
problème
j'aurais été très confiant de trouver
quelque chose
non mais sûrement la raison pour
laquelle saute pas sur ce coup parce que
s'il peut venir sur le 4 impunément bien
sûr ça va libérer la casé fixe pour la
dame aussi et peut-être que j'ai 5 pour
aller vers le 3 F3 donc toutes ces
pièces vont pouvoir coulisser et venir
faire très très mal
[Musique]
on va prendre G5 3D 3 fou F5
mais il a peut-être encore un cavalier 4
puis on prend il se barre éclore
je sais pas ça me
bon ok c'est trop peut-être juste à cinq
aussi un des coups bêtes comme ça qui
qui sont chiants quoi
c'est déjà relou quoi
[Musique]
un peu peur tout ça mais bon on investit
tellement de matériel après il faut être
quand même bien sûr
c'est une bonne gueule
devant les caméras et un écran et
mettant une lumière dans l'inverse de la
polarisation donc le joueur voit l'écran
mais pas les caméras ouais bon après
c'est sûr que si tu si tu te penches sur
le sur l'histoire il y a moyen de faire
des jolies choses ah mais même comme on
voit dans Mission Impossible des fois
ils te font des faux des faux fonds
c'est le plus pratique
alors en tout cas Wesley c'est pas assez
de son fou quand même dangereux
parce que maintenant il y a blanche sont
vraiment faible
on voit un des schémas de maths pour se
mettre en place une dame arrive vers G2
il y a bien des choses que tu peux voir
avec une lunette mais avec des lunettes
mais que tu pourrais pas avoir 100 ans
et bien elle est cool ça existe ça j'ai
déjà vu c'est comme ça
je sais pas les trucs un peu infrarouge
aussi je sais pas où tu as des lunettes
spéciales
on s'intéressant on pourrait faire un
des ondes qu'on ne voit pas et que
certains spectre de couleurs une caméra
voit pas quelque chose qui est une
caméra voit pas mais qui a un homme
verrez ça va bien ici
les caméras avec des hasards des trucs
mais juste quelque chose de la caméra
elle pense qu'elle voit mais en fait
elle voit pas toi tu crois
question intéressante question
technologique
c'est pas beaucoup et puis assez casse
blanche autour du roi qui sont
cataclysmique
là
qui peuvent passer
au-delà d'être mal quasi aucune chance
de pouvoir gagner ce genre de position
ce rappelons-le il s'agit pas de
seulement faire nul qu'il s'agit
toujours possible mais il faut gagner
avec les Blancs
voilà Wesley hors pair
il a gagné
le championnat du monde 2019 des chèques
960 montrant quand même toute sa classe
de la même fin vient cette colmater et
dans ses rêves les plus fous il espère
pouvoir doubler les Torres sur la
colonne C attaquer un peu le pioncer 6
peut-être échanger les fous de case noir
installer cavalier un jour
c'est beaucoup de sites tout ça
ils sont intéressants de faire une
émission spéciale triche avec un
spécialiste
comment il s'y prendre
peut-être faut pas le faire en live en
fait
peut-être que Maxime sera très en forme
pour les prochains tournois vous avez
peut-être voir une belle rayonner
rayonner et survoler les tournois
en quelques semaines
en tout cas comme vous le voyez avec
cette discussion c'est très très
compliqué en réalité de tricher parce
que les oreillettes on va aller voir la
caméra si c'est des des
lentilles on va aussi le voir les
lunettes pareil donc c'est vraiment pas
évident non non faut vraiment des
technologies pointues pour y arriver
vraiment des technologies très pointues
il faut vraiment avoir pris le problème
à bras le corps et y avoir pensé on peut
pas s'improviser
les méthodes de sécurité permettent
quand même de décrémer la majorité des
techniques ça les érudits peut-être une
chance
j'ai un petit peu qui se fait rattraper
un petit peu la pendule
une belle position rappelons-le
les voyants sont ouverts pour l'instant
pour Magnus
le deuxième petit coup marlou
dame F5
je sais pas pourquoi
ça rend le coup de con quoi bon après
faut regarder mais
bon
après
très étonnante très étonnant il veut
être amené son foot G4 en fait je ne
sais pas trop sinon pourquoi la tour
sera ici qui vais ramener le four en D7
pour complètement courir ces 6
et stand dans la position je sais pas
je m'y attendais pas à ce que je
voudrais plutôt ce qui double les tours
plutôt
enfin je veux dire
on ne pense pas trop forcément venir les
lames
mais intéressant ce que fait Magnus
une petite pression par rapport aux
caméras fin un jour ou quoi c'est toi
qui décide de la caméra que tu utilises
donc c'est pour ça que je demandais ce
qu'on peut utiliser une caméra sciemment
qui ne va pas des choses qu'on verrait
c'est pas du matériel fourni par
l'organisation d'accord ton matériel
donc
c'est une question intéressante question
que je me pose genre est-ce que nos
caméras elle voit tout ce qu'on fait
peut-être non même une webcam genre
classique ou un iPhone est-ce que il
voit mieux enfin il voit tous les
spectres qu'on voit nous et encore
d'autres mais ce qu'il y a des choses
que seul l’œil humain voit je suppose
qu'elle va mieux que nous en fait les
caméras
[Musique]
déjà ça éclaircit je crois
mais j'ai pas la certitude
même c'est un sujet très intéressant
écrasait la perspective aussi
j'ai scientifique Fabien
en tout cas on attend la victoire de
Magnus c'est
ce serait très mérité
qui s'accroche qui fait ce qui peut
peut-être aller chercher un Armageddon
ce match
4e partie
ils sont en qui s'égraine exorablement
la minute qui se rapproche
on va voir ce petit chrono passer dans
le rouge
ici deux secondes
et retire son fou pour peut-être essayer
d'échanger un petit peu des tours et
réduire cette pression
bizarre cette partie
qui souffre Magnus un peu en contrôle
qui arrive pas à complètement se matcher
pour finir mais qui pour l'instant en
tout cas vraiment de gros problèmes
les blancs qui s'en sortent pas ils
voient pas vraiment arriver à se
remettre à flot et encore moins être
menaçant
tout échanger aura une finale ce serait
ça son meilleur espoir en tout cas il
fait F3 il chasse ce fou il peut être si
un jour il peut faire E4 partir de
l'avant qui savent qui c'est
espérer vous avez aussi un moment un
coup comme GK3
le temps de colmater
et une bonne partie
et dès la fin du temps vous enverra en
raid sur la chaîne officielle ah oui
évidemment
[Musique]
pour ne rien rater pas une miette de ce
tournoi
et jouer 4 assez vite il prend sa chance
peut-être sale chance
alors c'est dû commencer la remise du
trophée c'est pour ça qu'il faut qu'on
regarde
c'est pour ça qu'on va devoir regarder
Fabien
mais ouais Magnus il fait pas une grande
partie finalement
une belle position mais bon il arrive
pas pour l'instant à conclure avec c'est
parti où tu dois faire que nul ils sont
un peu spécial souvent
au final
après ça se comprend
un petit peu défendent ce point sensible
en des quatre
c'est 4 à nouveau l'option
passer il y a de créer ça c'est un des
objectifs il a nettement amélioré sa
position mais peut-être il va pouvoir
faire G4 maintenant Wesley et tenter un
va tout et tenter un bateau
croiser les doigts
je ferais bien ici
calmer tout ça très vite
c'est un peu comme la partie d'avant il
réussit pas
de terminer F6
à ce moment là
qu'il s'en fiche il veut décaler les
tours par l'avant en tout cas il est
content d'avoir venir foncer trois et un
camion des deux pour prendre les cas sur
la colonne B il veut switcher tout le
jeu de l'autre côté et espérer faire
quelque chose évidemment prise et
damaset oh là là très jolie couleur
passée qui vont vraiment on sait très
vite beaucoup plus vite que les pions
blancs et le problème des blancs s'il
refuse de changer d'âmes c'est qu'il y a
cette dame qui rentre vers F2
qui va faire très mal ouais ça a l'air
d'être fini des chances de Wesley et
c'est Magnus qui va qui va s'imposer il
aura absolument jamais été mis en danger
Fabien de toute la compétition il aura
dominé ses adversaires de la tête et des
épaules
impressionnant impressionnant c'est
facile
on a l'impression qu'il aurait pu avoir
un point de handicap et gagner tous les
matchs sans vraiment problème tu auras
B7 tour B2 ouais il fait il fait C4
c'est bien joué aussi
il va tenter qu'elle prend ses quatre
peut-être pour C7 qui a valu trois
encore
si vite pour être sûr
des fois peut-être et tours c'est trois
tours c'est 7
il y a même temps français 4
français 4 et des deux oh il tombait
jusqu'au match
et on termine par un échec et mat ce
tournoi de roi remporté par Magnus
Carlsen la magnifique titre qui s'ajoute
à ce trophée qui s'ajoute à son étagère
déjà bien fourni mais c'est sûr qu'il
doit être fier d'avoir remporté ce
tournoi après avoir remporté le Grand
chest tour ce que je vous propose c'est
que je vais avoir rapidement le raid sur
la chaîne principale pour avoir les
impressions des joueurs et les
interviews et la remise du trophée merci
d'avoir suivi ce tournoi en notre
compagnie on se retrouvera à la fin du
mois pour la Coupe du monde à bientôt
[Musique]